[Music]
according to science fiction
a bigger brain means superhuman
intelligence it means you could solve
some of the world's most
complex problems in a matter of seconds
but would a bigger brain really make you
smarter
[Music]
why do some experts think that
intelligence is based more
on your blood flow and how would our
bodies have to evolve
to support a bigger brain
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if your brain was twice its size
the average human brain weighs about
1300 to 1400 grams
about 3 pounds if that were to double to
2 700 grams that would mean
a lot more weight for our bodies to deal
with
our necks would need to be larger and
stronger
our shoulders would have to be broader
to support that extra weight
and as a whole our bodies would need to
be
much thicker they might not seem like
that big of a deal but
these new physical features could cause
a lot of problems
for instance what kind of effects would
they have on
childbirth
it might seem a little far-fetched to
think of our brains as
continuously changing in size but in
reality
it's been happening throughout our
entire evolution
our ancient relatives homo habilis had a
brain
one-third the size of ours and over the
past two million years
it evolved to be the size it is today
[Music]
using this example you might be thinking
well
we are clearly more intelligent than
they are and we have bigger brains so
therefore a bigger brain equals more
intelligence
but that's not the case our brains
stopped growing about 20 000 years ago
when we developed stone tools
and we'd like to think we've become a
bit more intelligent since then
but during the past 20 000 years of
human progress and development
our brains have shrunk by ten percent
[Music]
a meta analysis of over eight thousand
brains was conducted in two thousand
fifteen
the researchers found that the size of
our brains accounted for only about
six percent of the difference in iq
between people
researchers from the university of
vetwatersrond in south africa
found that the rate of blood flow to the
brain
may be a better indicator of
intelligence the rate of blood flow to
the brain
seems to have increased in all primate
lineages over time but
in the hominin lineage the one that led
to us
it increased quicker this increase went
side by side with the development of
tools the use of fire and
communication within small groups so
if your brain were to double in size
it's
not likely that your intelligence would
double along with it
sorry about that instead it would just
introduce a lot of problems
[Music]
as we mentioned our bodies would become
thicker overall to
support the greater weight in our heads
this would likely be good news for the
massage industry because
our necks and shoulders would likely
feel sore more often
but it would be bad news for expectant
mothers
not only would each fetus need much
higher amounts of nutrients but
vaginal births would also become
extremely difficult
they might become obsolete and cesarean
sections could be the new normal
and the issues don't stop there because
of the extra energy we'd need to support
our bigger
heavier brains people could become less
mobile
and our bodies might grow much slower
and we might not get as tall
so maybe we don't want a larger brain
after all
who knows if our brains will continue to
shrink or
if they'll start getting bigger again
whichever direction evolution decides to
take us
you can be sure that technology will
play a big part in it
maybe one day we'll just upload our
brains into some
giant cloud computer but
that's a story for another what if
hey everybody if you liked this episode
and you want to take a deeper dive into
the topic of bigger brains
check out our episode of what if
discussed we speak with professor michio
kaku
about the complexity of the human brain
and how our brains
will eventually become digitally
immortal
you